do you still go clubbing do you still
cut a rug
I've never ever been to a club in my
life
what a terrible yes
very sorry for me you light like a rug
oh do I yes I've never been to a
nightclub yes you have I went into you
in heaven
[Applause]
absolutely true they took us
into the back door wouldn't they
[Applause]
story of her life
oh that is the only time is that really
the only time yes did you not have a
nice night you look like you're having
fun yes I think we did
I've never been to heaven
that's astonishing why were you there
for God's sake that's a good question
too
I know the answer to that as well
you'll be there to see share what you
were there to see Cher the singer share
oh yes that's right
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
s are cut out of the photograph
oh come on England catch up to the rest
of the world
page three material but it's true you
didn't like you you didn't like it well
it's it's I mean when you think of you
know having sex with someone you're
normally alone normally
[Music]
you know me so well already Henry in
this case maybe no one else with you
Graham
yeah the Swedish part no it's true did
you know this what tell him temper is uh
Swedish for vagina
I have a tiny vagina
is that is that true no it's not but I
was like why why why are you tiny not
why but is if that's true I know why I
know why why I don't know what I'm
saying because I heard that when you
were trying to figure out your name you
know like your your music name that you
want that you looked up anger right yeah
and then and then you were like oh
temper like tempering yeah
somebody Googled a guess
performance back in the dressing room
you do on this couch last names you
gotta be yeah gotta be up on one if we
had all your names it's like the
ultimate Scrabble score
Delevingne it's it's good it's good
right and before we go let's make this
week's visit
that's a lot
the sensible shoes who cares
oh my God time for a visit to the big
red chair who's there hello hello hi
what's your name my name is Anita Anita
lovely and uh where do you live in Utah
I live in Manchester and it's my
birthday today
all right
what
does he want a prize we were all born
that is cold it's my birthday whatever
you're brand new yes yeah he's quoting
your song back with you yeah it's good
hello hi I have my doubts
what's your name Nina sorry Nina Nina
yes like an ambulance very good
[Music]
finally finally you keep rally what's
going on
finally a decent bread person
[Applause]
telling British stories
off in a red chair by an Irishman
's been around for years
Nino sorry to hold you snap and so I'll
have to go with this story okay when I
was 20 I moved to Spain and I was really
keen on learning the lingo and obviously
the first word as you call it sorry my
colleague started to give me words of
the day so one day my word of the day
was chicken
so we go to the supermarket and very
confident in ordering chicken I give my
order to the butcher everyone starts to
laugh around me and I'm like why are you
laughing my friend next to me is rolling
around on the floor laughing and he told
me I'd got the word chicken confused
with the word penis
I can only apologize
I'd be happy to wait sit back for a
second
[Applause]
all right here we go can we have a
little music maybe something that's a
little ominous okay here we go wow yes
okay okay here we go you can do it to me
yes
get ready here we go
[Music]
laughs
beautiful very good
thank you thank you so much that's
sustained smoldering yes it is it's very
impressive yes but that Kevin yeah
Kevin is pregnant
thank you
I mean people are pulled out of the
audience yes to take part in this it is
very Hands-On you will uh you will get
what you give in the show I can
guarantee you oh yeah okay and you say
no can you say no can you say please
don't yeah yeah no I promise when I say
like the guys we have some of the best
guys they're all like they all love
their mom they're all like really really
good
guys I know it sounds silly but it's not
easy to give a lap dance like to get up
in somebody's space and to do it halfway
where you're like not feeling attacked
like you kind of need to be a good human
being very very
there are days when I just don't feel
like it
I'm not in the mood Graham but I have to
go out there I gotta do
TS
but I think I'm right you said I think
there's something about mail stripping
that it's just more good humored like
the audience of laugh and it's it's sexy
but it's funny at the same time in a way
that kind of I think women's strip clubs
are quite Grim yeah because it's like
carnal you have some guy that's like ah
yeah
just like trying to embarrass their
friends I think yeah it's a good it's
good fun I I don't know I enjoyed it
when I did it but these guys when I say
they're the best dancers in the entire
world we have class class a dancers and
performers but they get hurt apparently
yes it we've had some injuries yes
some I can't say on TV but um how did
that happen there's a lot of sliding
involved
a little splinter
yeah it is a wooden stage that was a bad
choice on our part
um but actually the most and the most
common uh thing that takes one of our
dancers out is a cold common cold
because you are very close and intimate
and some people don't care if they're
sick they just keep coming to the show
the dangers of lap dancing with no idea
common cold
thank you
but apparently and you wouldn't expect
this in the show there's quite a sort of
sweet tender moment yes so what happens
there can I show you
oh
I
um
[Laughter]
[Applause]
if everybody would like to join in
um there feel free to this is one of my
favorite moments in the show it's uh
it's a slow dance when's the last time
you slow dance with somebody years you
can still dance with your partner's next
to you
yes music please
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
oh the cameras are broken we've got to
do that again
well thank you very much no it really is
like my favorite part of the show like
everyone gets to slow dance with whoever
there's like standing next here it's um
it's quite nice thank you
he does smell lovely
[Music]
foreign